In 2017, the Supreme Court legalized sports
betting. It's become lucrative enough that
DraftKings, one of the most popular betting sites,
debuted two new ads during the Super Bowl. The
prospect of taxing gambling revenue has state
governments all over the country queuing up to
take full advantage to supplement their budgets.
But who will really benefit? Consider New York:
Governor Andrew Cuomo, ever the central planner,
wants to use the state lottery commission
to license just one gambling site that would
agree to share the most revenue with the state.
That means New York bettors won't
be able to choose from among the 10
major online sports betting services. It means
the state cares more about tax revenue than giving
bettors the best odds, and it means a state budget
ever more addicted to one more regressive sin tax,
like the lottery itself. It's neither good for
bettors nor a healthy way to balance a bloated
state budget. Other state governments beware.
Do you think state government should tax online
sports betting? Let us know in our poll. Also let
us know what other topics you'd like our scholars
to cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.